Transcriptor: Katia Cisneros
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Después de 9000 horas de entrenamiento,
más de 3000 zambullidas,
cientos de carreras,
varias medallas de oro,
toco la pared en Tokio 2020,
me di cuenta de que no hice
ni el tiempo que quería
ni terminé en la psocicion que soñaba.
Y en lo único que pienso en ese momento
es en qué me iban a decir
en las redes sociales.
¿Cómo podía ser que
lo que más me importara
fuese la mirada de un montón de personas
que ni conocía?
Ahí registré hasta dónde había llegado
mi exposición
y la comodidad con la que la gente
y los medios opinaban de mí.
De lo que hacía o dejaba de hacer.
De mis sueños y objetivos,
tomándolos como suyos.
Y yo esclava de eso.
¿Saben lo que pesa ver durante meses
tu nombre en los titulares de los diarios
prometiendo una medalla?
Sentía como
si dejara de ser una persona.
Que lo único que valía en mi vida
era entrenar y ganar la dorada.
Que el resto
ni servía.
Y lo peor es que eso
termina afectando la visión
que se tiene de uno mismo.
Había llegado a creer
que no me lo merecía,
que no podía ni disfrutar de estar ahí.
Había dejado de escuchar
mis propios deseos.
Es como si te pusieran unas orejeras
y te marcaran un camino
del cual no se puede salir
o siquiera cuestionar
la vida o carrera que uno tiene.
Me sentía sola.
Hasta que me di cuenta
de que compartía esa soledad
con otros atletas.
En Tokio 2020 pasó algo.
Se empezó a alzar la voz,
a hablar de temas,
hasta en es momento, ocultos
como la salud mental.
Y también a romper ese tabú
de que éramos superhéroes sin fallas.
¿Se imaginan lo significativo
que fue para mí
escuchar a Simone Biles,
la cara de las Olimpiadas,
hablar de la presión y la competencia?
Ella también estaba sola.
Ahí aprendí
la importancia de tener una cabeza fuerte
y de estar bien con uno mismo
para poder estar bien con los demás,
con nuestro cuerpo,
con la actividad que realicemos;
de poder vernos a nosotros mismos.
Y creo que ahí
empecé a sanar.
No me entiendan mal.
Amo lo que hago, desde siempre.
Mi mamá es profesora de natación
y también un poco bruja
por llamarme Delfina.
A los 8 meses, me metió por primera vez
en el agua y nunca más quise salir.
Es mi segundo hogar.
Al principio, me la pasaba
todo el tiempo en el club
donde ella trabajaba.
Mi abuela me buscaba en el colegio
y me dejaba ahí.
Yo corría al vestuario y directo al agua.
Era mi lugar para jugar,
para disfrutar,
donde me sentía más segura.
Ya los 13, me di cuenta
de que quería algo más.
Soy muy competitiva.
Tenía hambre de ganar algo, lo que sea.
Cuando llegué al club me dijeron
que primero tenía que federarme;
clasificar en un nacional,
competir y ganarlo
para pasar el Sudamericano
y así ir subiendo niveles
hasta los Juegos Olímpicos.
Yo dije: “Ya fue, vamos”.
(Risas)
Y cuando empecé a ganar y ganar,
más crecía mi amor
por la competencia y por el agua,
por la adrenalina previa
a subirme al cubo de partida
y la sensación hermosa
de haberlo dejado todo
terminada en la carrera.
Crecía mi confianza.
Y cierto ego, también,
que creo que todo deportista lo tiene,
te lleva a querer ser distinto
y querer ser el mejor.
Pero también, quienes me rodeaban
me empezaban a ver más
y creaban sus propias expectativas
sobre mí.
Sin darme cuenta,
me estaban colgando una mochila.
Esas miradas se fueron expandiendo
más allá del ámbito deportivo.
Al principio, era todo copado.
Pero como te empiezan a pedir fotos,
reconocerte en la calle,
que lleguen invitaciones
a lugares y eventos,
que tu nombre y tu imagen
empiecen a ser algo.
Aparecieron las grandes marcas de sponsors
y la exposición en redes aumentó.
Como toda adolescente,
los likes se convertían
en una muestra de aceptación social.
Y yo los buscaba.
Los primeros roces con la fama,
por así decirlo, eran divertidos
y sin ser todavía masivos,
los podía controlar.
Incluso, me di cuenta de que
podía motivar a otras personas;
trascender más allá de una medalla,
al dejar una huella en sus vidas.
Y también durante la pandemia,
ayudar a que mucha gente
se sintiera menos sola y desanimada.
Pero como todo,
hay un lado B.
Toda esa energía y adrenalina
que vamos sintiendo los adolescentes
a medida que vamos creciendo,
descubriendo quiénes somos,
cometiendo errores
y caminando hacia la adultez,
en mi caso, se convirtió en un tsunami
de miradas que llegó a un punto
que no había manera de controlarlo
y yo me ahogaba.
Tuve que madurar cosas muy rápido.
Mientras mis amigas organizaban
el viaje de egresados,
yo me levantaba a las 5 de la mañana
para ir a entrenar antes de ir al colegio.
Cuando falleció mi abuela,
horas antes de entrar a la Villa
Olímpica de la Juventud, en 2018,
no la pude despedir
hasta que finalizó la competencia.
El duelo, suspendido,
por representar a mi país.
Y cuando finalmente llegué a mi sueño,
a un Juego Olímpico,
terminé inmersa en una guerra
en las redes sociales,
donde me atacaban sin impunidad,
detrás de un perfil en Internet.
Donde me llegan a decir:
“Fracasada de mierda”.
Y lo peor
es que yo me lo creí.
Aprendí por mi cuenta,
de frente, a los golpes,
surfeando olas, prácticamente sola,
rodeada siempre del cariño de mi familia
y de otras personas,
que no eran especialistas
en los temas que yo necesitaba.
Tuve que aprender la forma de dar notas;
de qué decir o no decir
en las redes sociales, de qué manera.
De cómo tratar a una oleada de hate.
De entender
que las redes sociales
era un tema artificial.
Que después en la vida real
no me pasaban esas cosas,
ni sufría esos ataques.
Aunque parezca mentira,
esto, para mí, fue un gran descubrimiento.
Con otros atletas, tuve que aprender
a convivir con las presiones
y las expectativas de los demás.
Creo que lo que me pasó a mí
y a otros no es inevitable.
Creo que existen posibilidades
de crear mejores barreras de contención
con profesionales de distintos ámbitos
para ayudar a cuidar a la persona
que hay detrás del atleta
de alto rendimiento.
Es cuestión de posar las miradas
donde realmente hay que hacerlo.
Y eso es lo que estoy tratando de hacer.
Ver a la Delfi persona
y no solo a la deportista.
De poder valorar a ambas.
De darme cuenta de que,
cuando me zambullo al agua
y sigo la línea negra
en el fondo de la pileta,
obvio que tengo que tratar de nadar
lo mejor que pueda.
Pero cuando se acerca esa pared final,
cuando llega el momento de tocarla
y saco la cabeza del agua,
lo único que tengo que mirar
es a mi familia,
a mis amigos,
a mi abuela,
y a la Delfi peque
que solo quiere jugar
y que va a salir corriendo
para volver a tirarse al agua.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)